tengo cuatro afirmaciones aquí y quiero
que pienses cuál de estos cuatro
denunciados son ciertos el primero de
ellos dice un objeto en movimiento
disminuirá su velocidad a menos que una
fuerza desbalanceada actúe sobre él en
la dirección del movimiento interesante
de verdad el segundo de ellos dice un
objeto en movimiento mantendrá su
rapidez y dirección por siempre a menos
que una fuerza desbalanceada actúe sobre
él también es un enunciado interesante
el tercero dice un objeto en reposo se
mantendrá en reposo a menos que una
fuerza desbalanceada des perdon
desbalanceada actúe sobre el que tal y
finalmente el cuarto un objeto sobre el
que actúa una fuerza desbalanceada
siempre acelerará en dirección de la
fuerza entonces en este momento quiero
que hagas una pausa y reflexiones cuáles
de estos cuatro enunciados son ciertos a
lo mejor todos son ciertos o ninguno o
quizás algunos si algunos no no sabe
así que piensa cuáles de estos pueden
ser ciertos
así que suponiendo que ya hiciste una
pausa y ya pensaste al menos un poco o
al menos sobre alguno de estos
enunciados vamos a ir analizando los uno
por uno el primero dice un objeto en
movimiento disminuirá su velocidad a
menos que una fuerza desbalanceada actúe
sobre él en la dirección del movimiento
y esto en principio puede ser bastante
consistente con lo que es nuestra
experiencia cotidiana verdad si nosotros
tenemos no sé digamos aquí está el suelo
y queremos mover una televisión ahí
tienen ustedes una televisión y nosotros
queremos moverlo pues nosotros para
poder moverlo necesitamos aplicar una
fuerza una fuerza digamos de empujar la
verdad sin embargo en nuestra
experiencia diaria si nosotros empujamos
nuestra televisión pues nosotros no
veremos que sigas un movimiento por el
resto de los siglos sino que
eventualmente se detiene entonces en
principio uno podría decir que este
enunciado es cierto pero tenemos que
recordar muy
muy bien qué es lo que está pasando en
realidad aquí en el contacto con la
superficie está ocurriendo una fuerza de
fricción
está ocurriendo una fuerza de fricción
que porque está haciendo que esta
televisión después de empujarla ya no
empiece a decelerar a perdonarles a
acelerar por ejemplo si la fuerza de
fricción es muy grande quiere decir que
yo necesito mucha más fuerza para poder
mover esta televisión aunque entonces en
realidad si uno solo empuja en no
estaríamos contando todas las fuerzas
que están involucradas sobre esta
televisión nos faltaría por ejemplo la
de fricción entonces este enunciado es
falso es falso en realidad si nosotros
tenemos un objeto de un no sea una
cajita o qué sé yo si nosotros tenemos
un objeto en el espacio exterior o
digamos que está en el vacío no hay no
hay nada no hay aire no hay nada y él
excepto este objeto si nosotros lo lo
movemos o si lleva cierta trayectoria en
alguna dirección mantendrá su movimiento
en él con velocidad constante porque no
le estamos imprimiendo ninguna fuerza
externa si nosotros le aplicamos
la fuerza desbalanceada a este cuerpo
que se está movimiento que se está
moviendo con velocidad constante
entonces si su movimiento va a cambiar
de dirección o de rapidez también
entonces el segundo nos dice un objeto
en movimiento mantendrá su rapidez y
dirección por siempre a menos que una
fuerza desbalanceada actúe sobre él y
este enunciado es correcto es justamente
lo que habíamos comentado en este
ejemplo de nuestra cajita en el espacio
exterior verdad sí sí lleva cierto
movimiento nosotros necesitamos una
fuerza desbalanceada para cambiar su
movimiento ya sea en dirección o en
rapidez o ambos y por supuesto en el
espacio exterior no hay fricción por eso
es que bueno más bien no en el espacio
exterior sino cuando este cuerpo se
encuentre al vacío no hay fricción no
hay aire no hay no hay ningún medio con
el cual que o más bien que le pueda
ejercer una fuerza de fricción ok
entonces para cambiar su movimiento
debería haber una fuerza desbalanceada
tercer enunciado dice un objeto en
reposo se mantendrá en reposo a menos
que una fuerza desbalanceada actúe sobre
él y nuevamente este enunciado es cierto
si nosotros perdón si nosotros tenemos
una caja que está que está en reposo y
nosotros queremos hacer que se mueva
pues nosotros tendríamos a lo mejor
podríamos o más bien pensamos lo al
revés si nosotros queremos que se
mantenga en reposo y aquí hay una fuerza
que actúa por la izquierda yo necesito
aplicar una fuerza por la derecha más o
menos o de hecho tiene que ser de la
misma magnitud para que esta caja no se
mueva y permanezca en reposo pero si yo
aplico dos fuerzas de la misma magnitud
pero en dirección contraria en realidad
estoy hablando de una fuerza balanceada
si yo quiero que se mueva entonces tiene
que ser desbalanceada alguna de estas
tiene que ser más grande que la otra ok
y finalmente tenemos un objeto
perdón un objeto sobre el que actúa una
fuerza desbalanceada siempre acelerada
en dirección de la fuerza y esto por
ejemplo si nosotros tenemos una nueva
mente una cajita y digamos que le
aplicamos una fuerza hacia cierta
dirección entonces la aceleración sí es
cierto que se va o más bien la
aceleración lleva el mismo vector que el
que utilizamos para la fuerza verdad si
uno empuja hacia la derecha la caja se
moverá hacia la derecha acción no empuja
hacia arriba la caja se moverá hacia
arriba y así en la dirección que tú
quieras y de hecho eso está explícito en
la en la segunda ley de newton otra
forma de pensar lo es y verse un objeto
que no está acelerando como como la
televisión que tenemos en este caso eso
significa que no hay fuerzas de las
balanceadas o de plano no hay fuerzas
que estén actuando sobre ese objeto pero
si las hay
entonces ese objeto por necesidad tiene
que acelerar